حر نقطه في وجه الارض ورايا
[موسيقى]
انت على سبيل المثال النوم النوم انت
بتنام حتى في الليل درجه الحراره بتكون 35
40 فانت بتنام ما فيش اكسجين المكان كله
الاكسجين قليل لان مع الحراره ما فيش هواء
ما فيش رياح ما فيش اي حاجه حر شديد
السحره احنا في مكان نهائي فتجهيز الاكل
كان صعب ولكن كان معنا هو اللي كان
بيساعدنا بننام في الشارع لان لو نمت في
اي مكان مقفول كخيمه او اي حاجه
من الحر ممكن تموت يعني درجه الحراره
عاليه جدا بتتكلم عربي
[موسيقى]
اهل القبيله اتوقع ان هم عايشين من مئات
هناك فجسمهم متعود جسمهم غيرنا البني ادم
جسمه بيتاقلم مع درجه الحراره اللي بيعيش
فيها على مدار السنه فجسمهم متعود زائد ان
هم عندهم نفسهم معين لبس خفيف بطريقه
معينه اكل معين البيوت معموله بطريقه
معينه بتدخل الهوا بشكل معين وتحجب
الحراره يعني تاقلموا عاشوا عايشين حياه
بدائيه ولكن عارفين يتاقلموا مع الجو
[موسيقى]
الهدف من الفيديو كان ان هو نوصل الناس
انها لازم تكون ممتنه للحياه اللي هي
عايشاها لان في ناس عايشين حياه يمكن مش
زي الحياه اللي احنا عايشينها ومتقبلين
حياتهم جدا فرد فعلا الناس اللي هو الحمد
لله الحياه بتاعتنا كويسه احنا عايشين في
احسن من ناس كتير وفي نفس الوقت كانوا
مظلومين ان في ناس عايشين بالمنظر ده
قدرت انا اعيش درجه الحراره دي واتاقلم
معاها لمده اربعه ايام